what did you want to be when you grew up
did you have like was it exactly that
would you have guessed this or said this
or was it something totally random I
wanted to be a nun or a librarian and I
kind of took a different route I don't
know what happens
I was I was at the library every day I
was at story time every day and I wanted
to be a librarian then I thought no I
really want to be a nun
an archaeologist you know hilarious I
played a nun at the Playboy Mansion in
Charlie's Angels too so you know what I
think sometimes it can all be a hybrid
yeah um Best Mistake you've ever made
that's a mistake I don't want to call it
a mistake my best mistake I ever made
was
I guess marrying Tommy
yeah
hahaha